Okay. So I'd like to welcome all of you, and thank you for coming to the Signaling
Pathways in Cancer
Major Symposium. This symposium is dedicated to
the memory of J. Michael Bishop, or Mike Bishop, who I'll say a bit about in a
second. This is the schedule for today, and we'll try to keep to
it because we want people to have a chance to ask questions.
If you do want to ask any questions, please come to the microphones because this is
live-streamed, and people won't be able to hear the questions if you don't come to
the microphone. Okay.
So I guess I can switch the slide.
So for those of you who don't know Mike Bishop, he was a giant in the field of
molecular oncology.
I started graduate school a year after he
and Harold Varmus made the seminal discovery
that endogenous
genes were related to retroviral oncogenes, and in
particular, that the viral SRC gene was related to
c-SRC. And it's difficult at this point to overstate
the excitement that was engendered by that discovery,
and I think that that discovery began what I called in a recent
student lecture, the grand convergence that unified viral
oncology, cancer genetics, chemical carcinogenesis, and chromosome
biology related to cancer.
So
Mike was
a very wide-ranging individual. He
actually was very polymathic. He was a great
writer.
He didn't just serve as a scientist who won major awards,
including the Nobel Prize for that discovery and the Lasker Award, but also
was the chancellor of UCSF for many years and led the expansion of
UCSF into Mission Bay, where a
lot of its science is located today.
So this has actually been a
bad year for losing giants in our field.
But no one was bigger than Mike, and it's an honor
to chair a symposium that's dedicated to his
memory. And in fact,
the topic of this session is a direct outgrowth of his
original discovery. So this session is going to focus largely
on two signaling pathways that are essential downstream of receptor tyrosine
kinases and also other receptors.
And these pathways are the RAS/ERK/MAPK kinase pathway and the PI3
kinase/AKT/mTOR pathway. And we'll
have
talks in the meeting from John Blenis
on the mTOR/AKT pathway. I'll be talking about SHP2, which is at
the beginning of the RAS/MAPK kinase pathway.
And Debbie Morrison will be speaking about RAF family
kinases, which are also in the RAS/ERK pathway.
And then, of course, these signals are transmitted to the nucleus where they
regulate gene expression. And our
rising star speaker, Ray Pillai, who's from
NYU, also will be telling us about one of the downstream
consequences of signaling through these pathways.
And I've noted on this slide how the components
of these pathways are really a robust source of oncogenes
and tumor suppressor genes, the oncogenes being shown in red and the tumor
suppressor genes being shown in green.
So without any further ado, we'll start with my
talk.
Give me a second while it switches.
Okay. So the work that I'm going to talk about today on new
insights into how SHP2 signals to RAS is really the result of
a very
detailed collaboration between my lab, the labs of Wolfgang Petty and
Rebecca Page at UConn, who have contributed all the
structural biology that I'll be talking about at the end of the talk, and
also some work by Jeroen den Hertog
in the Netherlands at Utrecht on zebrafish SHP2.
And the phosphatase community is a very nice community, and everybody was
really interested in solving this problem, and we all got together.
It's not solved yet, but I think we've made substantial and shocking progress in
the last couple of years. These are my disclosures.
Everything that's shown in red is peripherally relevant to this talk,
but I won't be talking about any work from any of these companies here.
It's all from the labs that I mentioned.
So this is a cartoon-like structure of SHP2.
It has two N-terminal SH2 domains, a central PTP domain, and a
C-terminus with two tyrosine phosphorylation sites that in response to many
receptors, but not all, can become tyrosine phosphorylated, and they
constitute binding sites for the adaptor GRAB2.
And SHP2 is expressed ubiquitously, and it regulates
normal cell survival and proliferation, primarily by the
RAS/ERK pathway, and that's why it's in this part of the
session today. It's required for RTK and PTK
fusion-derived malignancies and also for adaptive resistance to
RAS/ERK/MAP kinase pathway inhibitors.
But in addition, there are somatic mutations in SHP2 that
are associated with several leukemias, most prominently juvenile
myelomonocytic leukemia, which I'll say JMML in the future
because I can't say that fast enough,
and also some solid tumors in humans, especially in response to
other inhibitors. It's been
argued to have a role in checkpoint receptor signaling, particularly PD-1, but
four labs, including our own, have knocked out SHP2 in T-cells,
and there's no effect on PD-1 action.
In fact, PD-1 action is, if anything, enhanced.
So I think that remains questionable.
And there are multiple allosteric inhibitors that have been in clinical trials.
There's only a few that are still in inhibitors in clinical trials.
And as I'll show you on the next slide,
these allosteric inhibitors prevent the opening of SHP2, and
therefore, they shouldn't be viewed as typical kinase
inhibitors or other types of inhibitors as enzymatic inhibitors, but they're
really more like protein nulls.So,
there are two potential models for how SHP2 regulates
RAS ERK activation downstream of
receptor tyrosine kinases. And it's been known now for at least
20 years that SHP2 lies upstream of the RAS exchange factor SOS.
But even earlier than that, two groups, our group and Josi Schlesinger's group in
1994, when many of you in the audience were probably not born,
suggested that an adapter model where recruitment of
GRAB2 to those tyrosine phosphorylation sites in the C-terminus brought
SOS to the membrane and activated RAS.
And subsequently, our group and also Xin Jiang's group have shown that
that is not true for all receptors.
So in particular, in work that we have in-- That we
re-investigated this using mouse models, we've shown that it's required
for PDGF signaling and it's partially required for
FGF signaling, but it's completely dispensable for EGF signaling.
And that confirms work that we published in early 2000.
The other major model for signaling is what I would call the substrate model, in
which case SHP2 acts as an enzyme to
dephosphorylate one or more, as yet unidentified or
controversial substrates. And I can say
conservatively, including by people in this room,
that thousands of postdoc and graduate student hours have been devoted to try
to identify that substrate.
And I'll give you a spoiler alert. I'm not going to tell you what the substrate is
today, and that's because there isn't one.
Okay. So the way we came about this was,
we took advantage of those allosteric inhibitors that I told you about,
and we know that there are mutations that you can make in SHP2 that don't affect
SHP2 function, but that block its ability to bind the allosteric
inhibitors. And the primary one that we use in this, and that I'll be using in the
talk, is TMQL mutant. So what we do is we express,
sometimes inducibly, but sometimes constitutively, at levels similar
to the endogenous level, the TMQL mutant.
And then when we want to expose the-- And then we make second site
mutations in the TMQL SHP2, and
then we add the drug, and that inhibits the endogenous SHP2 and
exposes the effect of the mutant and allows us to determine the
effect of second site mutations. And that's how we found some of
that work I told you on the tyrosine phosphorylation site mutants that I don't have
time to show you today. So the first big surprise is shown on this
slide. So what you can see is that if you stimulate
RAS 3T3 cells with EGF and measure RAS
activation by a GLISA assay or by a direct pull-down
assay, you can see that a potent SHP2 inhibitor such as
RMZ-4550 completely blocks the activation of RAS by
SHP2 at two minutes of stimulation.
And if you re-express the TMQL mutant in the same cells
that's wild type, you can see that you completely restore RAS activation.
Now, we found that two different mutants, the CE mutant, so cysteine
to the essential catalytic cysteine to glutamate mutation,
or the cysteine to threonine mutation, only restored about
50% of activity. So right away, that was problematic because that should
be phosphatase dead, and it's only required for half the signal
that's being blocked by a full SHP2 inhibition.
But the real surprise came when we exchanged data with Matt Sells and Frank
McCormick, who were working on similar problems.
And they hadn't made all these mutants, and neither had we, but they had made one
mutant that we hadn't. And that was they had made the C to S mutant.
The C to S mutant is a mutant that a phosphatase lab would never make because it's
known to have trapping activity and therefore could give you a gain of
function. But in this case, the C to S mutant was completely dead.
And then we decided to make every mutant, well, not every mutant, but a lot of
mutants to that cysteine. And the really big surprise was
that this C to D mutation was not only wild type, but as you'll
see in the next slide, slightly hypermorphic.
So a mutation of the catalytic cysteine to-- First of all, different
mutations of the catalytic cysteine have different effects.
And second of all, mutation of the catalytic cysteine to
aspartate is actually normal for signaling, at least at two minutes.
This is not just true for EGF. It's true for FGF,
as shown on this slide, and also for PDGF.
So at least for three major growth factors, there's no requirement that
the C to D mutant is fully capable of activating signaling.
It's not just true in fibroblasts.
If you reconstitute
SHP2 knockout HEK cells, you again can restore normal
activation with the C to S mutant.
Sorry, with the C to D mutant and with wild type.
And if you look at
longer times downstream
of RAS activation, you can see that the C to D mutant actually sustains
activation. So at two minutes, it's the same as wild type, but it actually sustains
activation distally to that. And if you look at downstream signaling, you
can see that ERK activation is also sustained, and AKT activation is sustained.
So these data suggest that as you might have expected back in
1992 when we first cloned this molecule, that the
phosphatase activity is a negative regulator and turns off RAS ERK signaling.
But the phosphatase domain has positive signaling activity.
Okay, well, it's one thing to work in these abnormal cells like
3T3 cells and HEK cells.
What about mice? So I can tell you that the same thing is true in
mice. So if you make a C to E mutation and knock it into mice,
what you can see is that this mouse is embryonic lethal at day 12 and a half.
We actually did this before any of those other studies, and we were perplexed by
this because the full knockout, which we made in 2006, is
embryonic lethal at peri-implantation. So it was earlier.
So we already knew there was something funny about the C to E mutant.
If you knock in the C to D mutation, not only is it not embryonic
lethal, it's Mendelian, and the mice are fine.
This is the phenotype of the
C to D mutation. And these mice are viable and
healthy, and they have only mild phenotype, which I'm not going to have time
to discuss, and only in females.This is not just
true in mice, it's also true all the way down to zebrafish.
And here we collaborated with Sarun Thanharttakul's lab, and particularly
Daniel Witterson, and more recently Tammy Belsha.
And in zebrafish, if you knock out both alleles of SHIP2,
there's two alleles of SHIP2, PTLN1 A and B, there's no
swim bladder and there's cardiac defect,
cardiac edema. You can rescue that with wild-type zebrafish
SHIP2. The C/D mutant is like the null, and the
C/D/D mutant is perfectly normal.
So again, across all those years of evolution, the C/D mutant is
perfectly capable of signaling. So as I mentioned earlier,
SHIP2 in the context of certain mutations in the SH2
domain, can act as a somatic leukemogenic mutation or
myeloproliferative disease mutation.
And the most strongest of these mutations is the E76K
mutation. And you can assay this in a surrogate assay in human TF-1
cells. So you can see that if you express um wild-type
SHIP2 and then you remove growth factor, GM-CSF, that those
cells don't grow. They don't die in TF-1 cells, but they don't grow.
If you
use wild type E76K SHIP2, now you can
see that you get factor independence.
If you put in the C to S mutation with EK, as we have reported in
2006 in mice, you don't get transformation.
But if you put the C/D mutant in, it's perfectly capable of signaling, and even the
C/D mutant itself can confer factor independence to the TF-1 cells.
So both normal and oncogenic signaling can be conferred by the C to D mutation
of SHIP2.
So that led us to the most important question.
I won't curse because I'm already in trouble.
What's going on? Okay. So the first thing you're probably
wondering is, are these phosphatase people just stupid and the essential catalytic
cysteine is not essential? So we tested all of these
mutants in a biochemical assay, either as isolated catalytic domains
or in, as you'll see in a second, in a full-length phosphatase domain.
And the C/D, the C/E, the C to S, the C/D/D
mutants are at the limits of sensitivity of the assay,
they're at least 20,000-fold dead.
20,000-fold dead is dead enough for me. So that's dead.
And the full-length proteins also lack phosphatase activity in
cells in an immune complex peptide substrate malachite green
assay.
Okay, so that's when we figured we needed some biochemical help,
or at least some structural biology help.
So we turned to Wolfgang Petty, who is an expert in NMR
spectroscopy, and he looked at the NMR spectrum of the
catalytic domain of CD and compared it to wild type.
And what you can see here in this difference map or CSP plot is that
there's relatively little difference between the NMR spectrum of the
wild type and the
C459D mutant. So you can see the blue is really pretty much
the same, but there's gigantic differences in the C to S mutant.
So the C to S mutant and the C/D mutants intermediate.
So I don't have time to show you that, but basically the structure of these domains
is quite different.
So at the same time, Yashika Aggarwal in my lab was
working with Eli Rothenberg
to set up an assay for SOS activation using
super-resolution microscopy. So Yashika had knocked
in a halo tag into the C terminus of
SOS1. And what you can see is if you stimulate cells with EGF,
you get an increase in SOS recruitment in the membrane or SOS1 density.
You get an increased number of SOS1 molecules in clusters, where we define a
cluster of three or more molecules within a 10-nanometer linking distance,
and this is all done by STORM in TIRF mode.
And
if you add RMC, you completely block the recruitment of
that. And there's also an increase in the number of clusters per cell in the wild
type.
Now, if we use our drug-resistant mutants and we now stimulate with
EGF, you can see that if you stimulate with EGF in the presence of the
drug, again, you reproduce the effects that I just showed you.
There's an increase in SOS density at the membrane, there's an increase in SOS
molecules in clusters, and there's an increased number of clusters per
cell. All of these things are enhanced in the C/D mutant, and they're all
blocked in the C to S mutant. So there's a correlation between the effects
that I just told you and the ability to form clusters in TIRF mode in
super-resolution microscopy. So then we wanted to drill down and try to
get some biochemical basis for these
cell biological observations. So we were very fortunate that I got
Adelson money and was able to collaborate with the Broad Proteomics
team for free. That is always good. Free is better than paying.
So they are really good at mass spec.
And
Yashika set up an experiment to do time resolved turbo labeling, where
we labeled with biotin for a total of about 10 minutes, and then we
stimulated and added EGF, and then took the turbo
ID collection at two minutes and seven minutes after
stimulation. And there's a lot of proteins that are labeled with SHIP2, and I don't
have time to discuss all of them, and that'll be the subject for another
talk. But you can see that there's one cluster of proteins that behave the
same way. They're up at two minutes in both the wild type and the C/D, but they're
sustained in the other. You can see that among these
proteins is SOS1.
So that impelled us or
suggested that we ought to look at the possibility the C/D cat binds
directly
to SOS1. So
what
Wolfgang Petty's lab did was they took the N terminus of
SOS1, including the regulatory domain, which comprises the histone fold, the
DH domain, and the PH domain, and they combined that with the REM
domain and CDC25 domain and split it in half, and what you can
see is that there's clear binding of the C/D domain
and also wild type to the histone fold PHD
domain. And you can tell that because there's a bunch of differences in the color
between the yellow and the blue in this 2D TROSY map.
On the other hand, there's no binding to the REM CDC25 domain.
So these data suggest that it binds directly to SOS1, and if
you break that down further, there's no binding to the histone fold, but there's
direct binding to the DH/PH domain of SOS.And
then,
fortunately, Wolfgang and Rebecca are married and also a one
family structural biology team because Rebecca is a
crystallographer and again, Sachin
Kadi and Hiep Nguyen in Wolfgang and Rebecca's group
solved the crystal structure of the DHPH domain bound to the
Sos to the CD domain. And there's a interface
that buries 900 angstrom squared
that comprises an electrophilic interface and also a
series of hydrophobic pocket.
And then Yoshika made 21 mutants across the predicted
interface by the crystal structure and also date residues that were supposed to
move by NMR. And you can see that many of these mutations are
no longer able to activate Ras or to activate Erk like the wild type, and
some of them are completely dead. But importantly, and conversely to the
CD mutant, all of the ones that are shown here in
the colors on the left-hand part of the slide are actually phosphatase
active in
a pull down malachite green assay.
So in other words, the CD mutation is phosphatase
dead and fully active to signal. And these mutants are phosphatase
active, but
either partially or fully unable to signal.
So I think that this squares the circle and completely separates phosphatase
activity from signaling by Ship2.
So in summary, and I know this has gone by relatively fast, but we don't get a lot
of time. The CysCAT or PTP structure,
the catalytic cysteine, or at least the structure created by the catalytic domain,
is important for Ras and Erk activation.
But phosphatase activity overturning 20 years of
dogma, largely we're responsible for, is not.
Instead, the phosphatase domain functions as an adapter to promote Ras
activation, while type and CD phosphatase domains bind directly to
the DHPH domain of Sos1, and multiple Ship2 mutants predicted
to disrupt this activation are signaling down, but phosphatase active.
And again, instead of being required for phosphatase
activation, SHP2 catalytic activity promotes Ras and Ras Erk
pathway inactivation. So I think this leaves us with a number of critical
questions, which in my dotage, I hope to contribute to solving.
One is, can the Ship2 Sos complex be targeted with Sos
molecules, for example, glues to lock it in place, or degraders that only see the
complex, which might give us a new type of Ship2 inhibitor that may be better
in the clinic? Are there other functions for Ship2 catalytic activity?
So again, I mentioned the canonical problem with the
checkpoint receptors. Our CD mutant mouse enables us to separate the
effects of Ras Erk activation from, for example, negative regulation
downstream of checkpoint receptors.
And I think that this has obvious implications for PTPN11
Rasopathy mutants, particularly those that are associated with
a Rasopathy called Noonan syndrome with multiple antigenes, which are all
phosphatase down, but probably now can be explained as being signaling
up. So I don't have time to go through revised models.
So I just want to stop and put up the acknowledgement slides.
I think I've mentioned everybody along the way, and thank you for coming,
and I'll take any questions in the few minutes I have.
Oh, and one other thing, everything I showed you, every single slide today, except
the
introductory slide, is unpublished, so please do not post
it.
Ben-
And not submitted.
Next week.
That went by in a blur, but-
Sorry
... the question I have relates to the two tyrosine phosphorylation sites-
Yeah
... in the C terminus of Ship2.
Mm-hmm.
So do you have an ability to monitor the tyrosine phosphorylation at
those sites? What's known about the proteins that interact with them?
And is it possible that the phosphatase activity, which has been evolutionarily
conserved-
Mm-hmm
... for literally millions of years-
Yes
... arguing for some parsimony in retaining function, is
regulating the tyrosine phosphorylation of the C terminal tail of Ship2?
It's not relevant for EGF. So if you knock in a double tyrosine
phosphorylation mutant of
Ship2, EGF activation is normal. It is required
partially and completely for FGF and PDGF respectively.
If you make a double mutation of the tyrosines and you fuse in GRAB2,
you can rescue the effect. So as far as we can tell biologically, the
only requirement of Ship2 is for recruiting GRAB2 to those
sites.
Okay.
And in terms of the phosphatase activity, we think it's being conserved to
negatively regulate and/or to have effect on other functions, not Ras Erk
activation.
So then the activation of Sos is a double effect in the sense that it recruits
GRAB2 Sos through the tyrosine phosphorylation sites, but there's also a second
mode of interaction.
For PDGF and FGF, but not for EGF. And we don't understand exactly what else
EGF is doing. That's a really important question.
Okay, thanks.
I can take one more question, and then we have to move on.
Maybe you already said that, and I didn't understand. Do you need GRAB2?
Who?
Right here. Ben.
Sorry. Hi.
Do you need
GRAB2 in all cases, or can you get rid of GRAB2
and just go straight from Ship2 to Sos?
So that's a good question. So I don't have time to show you those data, but we did
that experiment. So we made GRAB2 knockout HEK cells.
GRAB2 knockout HEK cells are very impaired in EGF
activation. Okay. They still have a very small amount of EGF
activation, and that is Ship2 dependent.
However, if you overexpress GRAB1, which is also a partner of
GRAB2, you can rescue completely the effects of GRAB2 knockout, and that
is Ship2 dependent, and it's CD mediated.
So our working model is that the critical role for GRAB2 in EGF receptor signaling
is to recruit GRAB1.
Okay, so our next speaker is John Planas,
and I don't have his title, but he'll tell you what it is.
Good afternoon.
I also am honored to be speaking in a session named after J.
Michael Bishop. Today, I'm going to talk about some of the signaling work that
we've been doing over the last several years, and these are my
disclosuresSo
I hate to say this, but for more than 30 years, my lab has been studying PI3
kinase, mTOR signaling, and the RAS/ERK/MAP kinase pathway.
More recently, we've been studying propionic acid metabolism, and this
is in the context of initiation of cancer progression and
metastasis in
cell survival and drug resistance.
As I've gotten older,
I've become more interested in the relationship
between our diet, obesity, aging, and cancer, and
so I'm going to touch upon that. Up till recently,
most of what we know about these connections is really correlational
and
based on
various population studies. But we really want to understand the mechanistic
links between these pathways and diet and
these diseases of metabolism.
So, I will not have time to talk about propionic acid metabolism.
A very talented instructor in my lab, Zhangqi Qi.
He'll be presenting a poster tomorrow in context
of diet and cancer and aging. Today, I'm going to
focus on PI3 kinase, mTOR signaling, and this is work by another talented
postdoc instructor in my lab, Nikos Koundouros.
So I'm going to start off by talking about the dietary
omega-6 and omega-3 fatty acids. So these are 18 carbon
fatty acids,
very similar. The only difference is that omega-6 starts at carbon six
and omega-3,
the double bond, starts at carbon three.
So these are essential dietary fatty acids, which means that our
cells don't make them. They can only come from the diet.
So the omega-6 and omega-3, once they come into the cell, they're metabolized by
the same enzymes. In the case of omega-6, they get metabolized to
pro-inflammatory cytokines like eicosanoids, prostaglandins,
leukotrienes, and thromboxanes.
Omega-3 gets metabolized to millime,
inflammatory eicosanoids, and inflammation-resolving resolvins and
protections. So why were we interested in these two?
Well, there's a lot of population studies and correlational studies that
suggest that a high ratio of omega-6 to omega-3, which
we find in our Western diets, which are unhealthy diets,
is linked to poor health, shortened lifespan, obesity, diabetes,
heart disease, and cancer. And interestingly, chronic mTOR signaling
is also linked to these diseases of metabolism.
Now,
a
so-called Mediterranean diet has an omega-6 to omega-3 ratio closer to
one to one, and these diets are associated with better health.
And interestingly, if you suppress mTOR signaling with rapamycin, for
example, in mice and monkeys with low-dose rapamycin, which suppresses mTOR
signaling,
this is associated with improved health and lifespan.
So because of these connections, we ask the question: Are omega-6
and omega-3 fatty acids
involved in regulation of mTOR signaling?
So we published this paper last year in "Science," so I'm going to go through some
of the data rather quickly.
First thing I want to point out is that FAPB5 exists in
the cytoplasm, also outside the cell and in your
serum, in your blood. What Niko showed was that when
omega-6 binds to FAPB5, it undergoes a confirmation change.
It exposes a docking site. If you make a point mutation in that docking site, you
block its ability to interact with Raptor.
Once it interacts with Raptor, it forms the mTORC1 complex, and you have signals,
and you get
proliferation. Now, interestingly, we did not see this in all cells.
So I'm going to focus on breast cancer.
We've seen this in prostate cancer and other cell types as well.
And what we saw was that
if you grow the triple-negative breast cancer cell line in a mammosphere
culture, you can see when they were exposed to omega-6 fatty acids, they
grow like crazy. Omega-3 has little impact on it.
But the hormone receptor-positive MCF-7 cells are not
impacted at all by omega-6 or omega-3 fatty acids. So why is that?
So we started characterizing the signaling a little bit.
These are one of the many triple-negative breast cancer cell lines that we work
with, these HSC18O6 cells. So if you starve these cells
and you stimulate them with serum, as you see with almost all cells, you get
activation of mTOR signaling and proliferation.
Now, if you take these cells, you starve them with serum, and instead of serum, you
add omega-6 or omega-3 fatty acids, what you see is
that omega-6 now activates mTOR
and stimulates proliferation.
If you knock down FAPB5 and you do the same experiment where you
starve and add omega-6 or omega-3 fatty acids, now you don't
activate TOR signaling and you don't get proliferation.
In contrast to the triple-negative breast cancer cell lines, the receptor-positive,
hormone receptor-positive breast cancer cell lines like MCF-7, as you
can see right off the bat, have very little expression of FAPB5.
So if you starve these and stimulate them, TOR gets activated and you get
proliferation. Now in these cells, if you starve and stimulate
them, there's no TOR activation and no proliferation, which is what I showed you in
that mammosphere assay. However, if you now
overexpress FAPB5 in these cells, what you
see is that omega-6 fatty acids now activate TOR,
stimulate proliferation. Omega-3 still does not.
Okay. We wanted to get some clinical relevance to this
new mTOR-regulated signaling pathway.
And one of the things that we did was we obtained a bunch of PDX tumors
from receptor-positive and triple-negative patients.
And we looked at the FAPB5 levels, and these triple-negative breast
cancer tumors have elevated FAPB5.
We also wanted to get some more direct evidence from patients.
So in a collaboration with Eleni Andreopoulou,
she provided us with serum samples from patients that were newly diagnosed receptor
positive or newly diagnosed with triple-negative.
And in the serum of these patients, they had elevated FAPB5 levels shown
here.Okay, so
we want to now go back and ask,
how do diets rich in omega-6 or omega-3 fatty
acids have an impact on all the things I just showed you in vitro and
link to what we see in patients? So we generated two diets.
The only difference in these two diets is the fat source.
So in the omega-6 enriched diet, the
main fat source is safflower oil, which is very high in
omega-6 fatty acids. For omega-3 diets, we use the
main fat source as flaxseed and fish oil, which generates a ratio of
omega-3 to omega-6 about four to one.
So typically, we put our mice on these diets.
In this case, about eight days later, we inoculated the mice with this
aggressive triple-negative breast cancer cell.
We can palpate tumors by about five days, and then we start
monitoring growth of these tumors, and at the end, we collect the tumors
and look at bulk tumor serum and interstitial fluid.
Interstitial fluid is the fluid that surrounds the tumor.
Okay. So,
we have a lot of data here, but I'm just going to focus on Fabp5.
So if you look at these triple-negative breast cancer cell
tumors, these xenografts, remember, these already have high
Fabp5, but if they're grown in an omega-6-rich diet,
they gain even more Fabp5. If you look
at their interstitial fluid and the
mice that were fed the omega-6 have higher levels of Fabp5 in
their interstitial fluid.
If you look at serum levels,
if mice were fed omega-6, they have high levels of
Fabp5 in the serum. We wanted to look at TOR signaling in these
xenografts, and seven out of the ten xenografts
exhibited high TOR signaling, and zero out
of the ten of the tumors fed omega-3-rich diets
had elevated TOR signaling. And then finally, we wanted to look and see
what the effect of omega-6 and omega-3 is on tumor growth, and you
can see, again, I want to point out, these are very aggressive cells, and in the
presence of omega-6 diet, they become even more aggressive, and they grow
faster than those tumors in the presence of omega-3.
Okay.
Now, this previous
slide, which I'm going to go back to, and also the clinical data I showed you.
So those patients that had triple-negative breast cancer, they had elevated
serum levels of Fabp5. Other experiments that we've done have suggested that
this might be the result of those cells
releasing Fabp5 and accumulating in the serum.
But we wanted to know if a dietary omega-6 diet
might influence Fabp5 levels independent of mTOR
signaling or independent of a cancer.
So we repeated that experiment that I just showed you, but this time, these
diets were being fed to mice without tumors.
And what you can see here
is that those mice that are fed an omega-6-rich diet
have elevated
proinflammatory cytokines like IL-6, and they also have elevated
Fabp5. We wanted to make sure that this had an impact on
the
TOR signaling.
And so what we see here is that those mice fed an
omega-6-rich diet had elevated TOR signaling in their normal pancreas and
the normal liver. Those fed an omega-3 diet had less
S6 phosphorylation and TOR signaling in both the liver and
the pancreas. And this led us to ask a few other questions that we've been working
on, and I'll present some preliminary data
addressing these questions. So the first one is, where
does the high serum Fabp5 in mice fed
an omega-6 diet, where does that Fabp5 come from?
I suggest that it comes from tumors, but also in tumor-free mice, we see an
elevated Fabp5.
And then what is the potential consequence of having elevated Fabp5
in your serum?
Then the other question based on the fact that we see very little phosphorylation
in omega-3-rich diet is, does an
omega-3-enriched diet promote suppression of
mTOR signaling?
Okay, so
before I describe this experiment, I should tell you there's lots of gene
expression data and some cell biology
that shows that
visceral fat adipocytes
express high levels of Fabp5, and it's secreted.
So we wondered if that visceral fat adipocytes secreted
Fabp5 might be playing a role in
our observations that omega-6 induces high expression of Fabp5.
So we set up a very simple in vitro system because we wanted to
subsequently do more biochemistry.
So in these cells, we took those MCF7 cells.
Remember, they have very little Fabp5, and we incubated them with
conditioned media from the same cells, and there's no difference on those cells.
However, if we take 3T3L1 adipocyte condition media
and we incubate that with MCF7 cells, all of a sudden they start accumulating
Fabp5, and those cells are now sensitive to dietary omega-6
fatty acids, which then activates TOR signaling, stimulates proliferation.
Now, we took that condition media, and we isolated Fabp5, and we found that it was
in these extracellular vesicles.
So we wondered how the extracellular vesicles are getting into cells.
So we just did the same experiment, but now in the presence of this
macropinocytosis inhibitor, and you can see that blocks the ability of these cells
to take up Fabp5 and be stimulated by omega-6 fatty acids.
So given this data and previous data I showed you and some other data that we
have in the cell, we have this general model that we're thinking
about. And so as I showed you, tumors that express high levels of
Fabp5 express high levels of Fabp5 in the
serum. If you're on a diet enriched in
omega-6 fatty acids, like the Western diet-You also have high levels of
FABP5 in your serum. And visceral adipocytes
or adipocytes, depending on if you come from East Coast or West Coast,
or in other words, obesity, can also result in high levels of
serum FABP5. This can be absorbed into cells,
and in the presence of omega-6 fatty acids, you get super activation of mTOR
signaling and cancer progression.
Without a tumor, we know that chronic mTOR signaling, which would be the case
if you have a high omega-6 diet, will also contribute to aging.
And then I also want to point out that if you have
dietary
omega-6 and also visceral adiposity,
this will produce enough FABP5 that maybe result in the
accumulation of FABP5 in those tumors that don't have high
FABP5, making those tumors now sensitive to omega-6 fatty
acids.
Okay. So what about omega-3?
What impact does that have on mTOR signaling?
So this was published in a paper, so I'll go through it very quickly.
What we found is that adding omega-3 to cultured cells
induces a degradation of
FABP5. So if you look at control in the presence of
omega-6, the half-life is about 24 hours, but in the presence of
omega-3, the half-life is about two to four hours.
So we have some evidence that's proteasome-mediated.
So we're trying to understand how an omega-3 fatty acid can induce the
degradation of FABP5. So that's one
experiment. I want to tell you one other thing that I think is super cool, and
that is that we started looking at the
serum of mice that were fed an omega-3 versus an omega-6 diet.
And we found this one metabolite.
It's a
microbiome-derived secondary bile acid called lithocholic
acid. And you can see those mice that were fed an
omega-3-rich diet have accumulated lots of lithocholic acid.
Why is that so exciting? Because in the last five years, it had been published that
lithocholic acid accumulates in the microbiome of
centenarians. So those are people that grow to 100 or more.
Lithocholic acid phenocopies anti-aging effects of caloric
restriction, which also inhibits mTOR signaling.
And lithocholic acid binds to a receptor to activate sirtuins and
AMP kinase to slow down aging. And AMP kinase is also a negative regulator
of mTOR signaling. So we wanted to characterize the signaling downstream of
lithocholic acid.
Oh, s**t. Okay. So this is a very busy slide
here. I'm going to focus on one time point, and that's highlighted here.
So if we add physiological doses of lithocholic acid to these cells, what
you see is AMP kinase gets activated.
This is a substrate for AMP kinase.
You see that mTOR is downregulated. So this has been shown.
This has not been shown. And ERK signaling also seems to be downregulated in
human cells, these HCC1806 cells.
And p38 MAP kinase signaling is activated in the presence of
lithocholic acid. And this is very exciting because this is a signaling
signature that is associated with improved health, longer lifespan, and reduced
tumor growth. So let me just summarize what I've told you.
So I've told you that
a dietary omega-6 can bind to FABP5, inducing a conformation change that
results in formation of the complex and downstream signaling by mTORC1.
I also showed you that mice on diets, omega-6 diets,
with a triple-negative breast cancer cell line engrafted in them,
the omega-6 diet will enhance the growth of these.
I've also shown you that
triple-negative breast cancer patients have
elevated FABP5 in their serum, and PDXs
from triple-negative breast cancer patients have elevated
FABP5 in their tumors.
I've also hinted at, and we're
really following up on this, is that visceral fat might be a source
of FABP5 that can be absorbed by tumor cells,
and in the presence of omega-6, this would make those even more aggressive.
And then
for omega-3, I presented some data that says that
omega-3, when it gets into the cell, induces a turnover of
FABP5. And mice fed an omega-3-rich
diet produced this microbiome-derived metabolite, lithocholic
acid, and that has anti-tumor and anti-aging effects.
So the reason why we do these experiments, why we're doing experiments, we
want to go beyond association with correlations and define mechanisms.
We want to also determine if dietary intervention can be used as a therapeutic,
likely in combination with current therapies.
And with mechanisms, we can begin to identify other therapeutic targets.
So for example, we've made an inhibitor that blocks this
interaction, and it works in cells and it works in mice.
So we're making second and third generation inhibitors now. Okay.
So I want to just end by, again, acknowledging Nick Conduras.
I have several people in my lab that interacted with him.
He's a really great interacting group.
Eleni Andrelopoulou is our breast cancer
oncologist collaborator. And CJ Grow and Nick Collins are
our microbiome collaborators. So with that, thank you, and happy to
take questions if I have time.
Thanks, John. That was great.
As you know, TNBC has major disparities
in incidence and outcome, and I'm wondering,
especially because your TNBC cell line is from an African
American patient, if you might have seen differences
with other cell lines or if there's an association
with disparities in TNBC with your
observations.
Yeah. So the African American population, many of
the African American population have these point mutations in FATS1 and
FATS2. So it forces the pathway to go downstream.
And so we
have not done experiments to address that, but that's something that we've been
thinking about
in addressing.And Neal
I noticed this is the inverse of the question you always ask me.
You look at S6K as the major marker downstream of TOR,
so I'm obviously going to say what happens to 4E-BP phosphorylation.
But what I'm more interested in is what happens to p10 expression
since p10, any activation of the pathway, ought to be
associated with p10 to some degree, and to some
degree will be balancing the homeostasis.
So I'm wondering if you looked at those yet.
So yeah, that's a great question. We have, in fact, looked at 4E-BP1.
It tracks with S6 kinase. But other targets of mTOR, like
ULK1, does not track. So we also have evidence that this is
signaling a little bit different than our amino acids
and growth factors, and may be
signaling from another location.
So this looks like it's going to be a quite unique
signaling system.
Hi, David Schleper for UCSD. Two questions.
I'm sure you probably showed it, but does the omega-6 diet
enhance, over regular diet, the tumor growth?
So if we add omega-6 to a chow diet?
Yeah.
Yeah, we have not done that because a chow diet is so different than our diets.
So there would be other-- Sorry?
So dependent on what?
You said so dependent on...
On omega-6 addition. Yeah. So the chow diets have a lot
of... It's very different from the makeup of our diets.
So I-
We'd have to account for that.
So your focus is on linoleic acid.
Omega-3 acids, EPA, DHA, are some of the main players.
How do they fit into this?
Yeah, so that's a great question.
So DHA and those downstream metabolites
are particularly rich in salmon, for example.
And flaxseed has the omega-3. And we have not yet looked
at each individual one. So that's something we clearly have to do.
Thanks.
So I had one more thought. Is this thing working? Ah, there it goes.
So John,
I'm a little confused about one thing.
You said that visceral obesity releases
FABP5, which is then taken up by tumor cells.
And you also showed that hormone receptor-positive patients have much lower
levels of FABP5. But obesity is much more correlated with
hormone receptor-positive cancers than triple-negative breast cancers.
So why don't obese hormone receptor-positive patients have high FABP5?
Yeah, so that's a really awesome question.
So in terms of
hormone receptor-positive cancers,
often they metastasize, and they lie dormant
after menopause.
Okay.
And after menopause, a lot of women put on a lot of weight.
And so we actually believe that that additional
weight that occurs may be involved in escape from dormancy.
But most hormone receptor-positive tumors occur in
patients after menopause anyway.
Sorry?
Most breast cancer occur in post-menopausal women anyway.
But those-
In fact, TNBC is much more common in younger people.
The timing for reoccurrence is much shorter.
Right. But you're looking at primary tumors, right?
In those FABP5 measurements.
Yeah.
Yeah. So I still don't... We can talk about it, but-
Okay.
Okay, that's great. So,
we're going to move on to RAF, and thanks, John.
You don't have to. The next
speaker is Debbie Morrison from NCI Frederick, and she's one of the few
people from NCI Frederick that was allowed to come to this meeting,
if those of you who heard Frank McCormick the other day.
So,
and we're really glad that she was allowed to come.
Thanks.
So my lab really focuses on the RAS pathway
and the role of the RAF kinases as a direct effector of RAS.
And as we know, this pathway plays a very important role
in the transmission of many normal growth and
developmental signals. So it's really not surprising when
this pathway becomes deregulated, such
as somatic mutations in a number of the components of the
pathway, such as RAS and BRAF. It can
lead to cancer. And
germline mutations in components of the pathway
can also result in a group of developmental
disorders known as the RASopathies.
And this has caused this pathway to be heavily
targeted.
And what we've learned over the years, I think, is
that in order for this approach to become most
successful, you really need to understand how signaling through the
pathway is regulated, with the bottom line being
the details really do matter. And for the RAF
kinases, which my lab really focuses on, their
mechanisms of regulation has turned out to be quite
complex.
And so there are actually three RAF family members,
ARAF, BRAF, and CRAF, also known as
RAF1, and they can really all be divided in
two domains, the catalytic domain, which contains the
kinase domain, and a regulatory domain, which has the
RAS binding domain and a cysteine-rich domain.
All of the RAFs can phosphorylate and activate their
downstream substrate MEK.
And if we're talking about their intrinsic activity, it's been
shown that BRAF by far has the highest
enzymatic activity, followed by CRAF, and then by
ARAF.
We've also learned throughout the years that there are a number
of proteins that play an important role in
regulating RAF activities, and these are proteins that interact with the
RAFs.And like many protein kinases,
the Rafs are clients of the
Hsp90-CDC37 chaperone
complex. And A-Raf and C-Raf have been
categorized as strong clients, while B-Raf is a
weak client except when it's mutationally
activated. And so the wild type cycles out of this
complex rather rapidly. We also know that
Ras interacts with the Ras-binding domain, and it
also interacts with the cysteine-rich domain,
which binds two lipids that are present in the
plasma membrane. There's also two
phosphorylation-dependent 1433 binding sites,
and the kinase domain can interact with its substrate
MEK as well as other Rafs.
In putting this all together, what we've known is that in an
active state, the Rafs are found in the
cytosol as an inactive monomer. But then
when Ras becomes GTP-loaded, it can actually
recruit the Rafs to the plasma membrane, and it
promotes the relief of autoinhibition
as well as resulting in dimerization,
which we know is very critical for Raf activation.
And I just am showing this slide to demonstrate that if
you make a mutation in the dimer interface, you can
actually lose
all dimerization. Here we're looking at homodimers of
B-Raf and C-Raf. And for this talk, I'm really going to be focusing
on B-Raf and C-Raf because those are the primary
drivers of human disease. And what you can
also see that when you disrupt dimerization, you completely
disrupt the ability to EGF to
stimulate the kinase activity of the Rafs.
And I'm also pointing out that in response to Ras
activation, what we primarily see is the
formation of BC dimers. We
see some homodimerization with B-Raf, but really
very little homodimerization with C-Raf.
And as I go on, I think we understand why that may be more.
But we know that dimerization is critical for
downstream activation of MEK and ERK under normal
signaling conditions, but dimerization also
plays a role in human cancer. And
dimerization of the Raf proteins are required
when you have activating mutations in upstream components such as
a receptor tyrosine kinase or Ras.
But in addition, B-Raf is a strong driver, especially the
V600E mutation in
cancer as well. But this is,
in fact, Neil Rosen's group has classified as a class
I mutation, where this one can actually function
as a monomer. However, for the class II and class
III B-Raf mutants, which either self-dimerize
or dimerize with C-Raf and are Ras-dependent,
dimerization is critical for their transforming activity.
And I think one of the first indications that understanding the
details is really important was the fact
that dimerization plays a role and
contributes to the paradoxical effect of the
first-generation Raf inhibitors and can
lead to drug resistance.
So
everything that I've told you so far about binding to
Ras, phosphorylating MEK, and being able to dimerize
holds true for all of the Raf family members.
But what we really wanted to understand is, are there regulatory
differences? And one thing that jumped
out at us was that there is one big
difference in the negative charge regulatory region,
with B-Raf having a constitutive negative charge,
where A-Raf and C-Raf are inducibly charged, but
through phosphorylation events.
And in addition, they have different lengths
of this N-terminal segment. And as I said, the negative
charge regulatory region plays a role in the
increased stability and the increased catalytic
activity of B-Raf. And we've learned that this
N-terminal segment contributes to Ras binding
selectivity and plays a role in preventing
inappropriate membrane binding for B-Raf.
And this is just shown in this slide here where we were
immunoprecipitating all the different Ras family members,
K-Ras for B here, H-Ras or N-Ras. And
if we immunoprecipitate the Ras and then probe for either
endogenous B-Raf or endogenous C-Raf, what we found
was that we saw equivalent binding with C-Raf.
However, we really saw a selectivity in binding to
K-Ras of the B-Raf protein, and that correlates with
the ability to activate MEK, and it also correlates
with the ability of these Ras mutants to promote
heterodimerization between B-Raf and C-Raf.
And we found that it was due to this N-terminal segment,
which is not only longer, but it also has an acidic charge.
Because if we then replace
the K-Ras, which has a polybasic
region on H-Ras, we found that H-Ras
could then recruit B-Raf. So we think that there is
an interaction between this acidic and this polybasic
region.And we also found that if you took and
depleted the entire N-terminus, then
HRAS on its own, with its own hypervariable
region, was able to recruit BRAF.
But in addition to looking at the structural differences, we've also
been looking at the disease-associated mutations.
And as we know, most of the cancer hot spots
are in the inhibitory turn, which is where the V600
mutation is present, but also in the P-loop,
which surrounds the GLYX6 GLY motif.
However, in the RASopathies, the developmental disorders,
the hotspot is completely different.
It's in the cysteine-rich domain.
And a few years ago, we looked at a panel
of these mutants in the cysteine-rich domain to try to
determine why these mutations caused an
upregulated activity. And what we found is that they
play a critical role in maintaining BRAF in
an inactive, non-signaling state.
And I think that really can
be explained if you look at the
cryo-EM structure of the BRAF protein.
And this was first solved by Mike Eck's group and really
revealed
the critical central position of the cysteine-rich domain.
This is the 14-3-3 dimer here. Here's the BRAF
kinase domain. And in our structure, which was
similar to Mike's, we had the CRD in this
cradle of the 14-3-3. But our structure also
had the RAS binding domain resolved.
And what you can see is the CRD makes critical contacts with
both the kinase domain and with the
14-3-3 protomer to hold this in an inactive
state. And what it does is it also
locks or obscures the dimer interface.
And if you look here at also what
maintains it also catalytically in an
inactive state is the alpha C helix is in the out
position. And this inhibitory turn where
V600 is,
it results in keeping it or helping to maintain or
stabilize the alpha C helix in an out position.
And there are also interactions between this P-loop and the
inhibitory turn that help also
stabilize this inactive conformation.
And when you have mutations in this region, the alpha C
helix can drop down. And I think recent work from Mark Thierman's
group has shown is when the alpha C helix comes down into
the active position, it results in structural
changes allowing the CRD to come out
of this inactive structure. And ultimately, you're able
to form the dimerized active complex.
And we've been wondering if there also are transitional states that
occur during the activation process.
And we've been collaborating with computational
scientists at the Lawrence Livermore National Labs, taking the
known structures where they conduct large-scale molecular
dynamic simulations, and we are testing and validating the
models. And for this project, we're using
KRAS that's G12D, that's tethered to an
eight-lipid plasma membrane. We're using a model of the
full-length BRAF, including the disordered
regions in an auto-inhibited structure.
And in their computational analyses, and there have been
over 100,000
simulations done with a cumulative time of 23.9
milliseconds. And what we found is that during all
of the simulations, the inactive BRAF, the
RBD, remained in contact with this
protomer of 14-3-3. And there were a lot of hydrogen
bonds that were formed here. And this was critical in actually
stabilizing the RBD such that the four basic
residues that form the ionic interactions
with the switch one region of KRAS were
exposed. And they also
revealed that when you started to engage RAS,
that there would actually be a clash or steric
hindrance as well as an electrostatic repulsion,
suggesting that RAS itself would start the
disassembly process of the auto-inhibited monomer.
And so to test this, we actually set up an in
vitro activation assay where we're utilizing purified
components. And in this, if we added fully
processed KRAS just to our inactive
complexes, we were able to activate BRAF
in a concentration-dependent manner.
We found that it required that KRAS be in the
GTP-bound state.
And we also found that it was
dimer-dependent. So what we're actually looking at in the
test tube is the ability of BRAF to interact with
KRAS and for the monomer to dimer
transition to occur.
And we also found that if we took soluble KRAS, we
were getting a certain level of activation.
But if we then coupled it to
lipid-containing nanodiscs, what
we found was that there was a synergistic effect on the
RAF activation that we know that this is
RAS dependent because the nanodiscs by
themselves did not change the RAF
activity.We've gone on now and
have actually used this assay to detect both
proteins and reagents or
inhibitors that actually can suppress the
monomer to dimer transition. And this is both
with using a purified protein of the RAS binding domain,
an inhibitor of RAS effector interactions, as well
as a RAF-MEK clamp.
But that's all about BRAF, where we've learned a lot.
But we were also interested in CRAF.
And what's really unusual about CRAF is if you look at the
hotspots for these associated mutations, they
occur in completely different parts of the
protein from BRAF, and this is
around the 14-3-3 binding sites
for both the RASopathies and mutations that are also
picked up in cancer. And we wondered if this tells us something
about CRAF regulation. And so we've also
been working to analyze the CRAF structure,
and what's different about our structures from some of the others
that have been reported is that we are isolating them from
human cells, stable cell lines. And the advantage
is that it allows for the physiological regulation to
remain intact. We can serum starve or growth factor treat,
and all associated proteins are endogenous.
And when we look at our BRAF monomers versus CRAF monomers,
what you can see is we do have an Hsp90 complex, as
well as a 14-3-3 MEK complex, and we've
been able to
get the structure of all of these complexes.
Like others, we're finding the Hsp90 is in very
similar orientation to what has been published.
But in our MEK complex, what we find, and again,
this is the wild-type RAF protein, that what you can
see is the CRD is not in the cradle
of the 14-3-3 dimer like it is for
BRAF. And we do have resolution of the RBD
here as well. And so,
I think what this is telling us is that the regulation of
the RAFs is not
completely-- There are subtle differences in that,
and we find that the structure and disease-associated
mutations indicate that the inactive state of
CRAF relies more on 14-3-3 binding, in
particular to the N-terminal site, as opposed to CRD
interactions. And for CRAF, all of the
activation is both RAS-dependent and RAF
dimerization-dependent. And I'll stop there and
just acknowledge the people in the lab and our collaboration
with the RAS Initiative, as well as the Lawrence Livermore
National Labs.
Okay.
Questions.
Thank you for that talk.
I continue to learn from all of the work you've done in this space.
My question is with the KRAS titration experiments.
I'm wondering if 365 is phosphorylated
in those experiments. So is it
phosphorylated or not, I guess is my question.
Is the RAF dephosphorylated as much?
At the 365 residue whenever you titrate it in more KRAS.
So
in cells, it does get
dephosphorylated. Not completely, but there is a
dephosphorylation.
Yeah.
All right. And then,
the preference that you showed for BRAF to KRAS
mutants over HRAS and NRAS, does that vary
based on the mutation type?
So, yes. There are some mutants. I know
Kevin Haigis is-- We're finding that there's a mutation, the
A59 residue, that can
vary that. And also, the thing I didn't have the chance to tell you is
that for NRAS and HRAS, if there's secondary
mutations or inhibitor treatments
that promote BC dimerization, then those
NRAS and HRAS can actually engage
BRAF to an increased level, and that seems to
contribute to some of their
oncogenesis as well.
Okay. Thank you.
All right. Quickly, we're going to try to squeeze in a couple more.
Thanks for the great talk.
So some studies found that
CRAF is more important, especially the dimerization of CRAF is
more important in KRAS mutant cancer cell line.
So
they did a knockout in vivo. They did a knockout and
found that CRAF knockout can abolish the
KRAS mutant cancer group, but not
BRAF. So,
I'm wondering, based on your study and your
understand, so do you have some insight
to share regarding the importance of BRAF or CRAF
in the KRAS mutant cancer?
Well, I think for the CRAF deplete, those studies,
they're looking at very distinct phases
in certain cancers. And I think this gets back to
where some of the details do matter,
and that in
our hands, if we take some of the cell lines, now we haven't
done this in vivo, but we do see that there is a
reduction, yes. And especially CRAF is very
critical as well. But
it's-In normal signaling,
what you do see even if KRAS, you
see the
dimerization.
And I think that those are actually important questions that
we still need to
further investigate.
Okay. You guys can fight over. One last quick question.
Which one's taking it?
Is it possible to make a compensatory mutation
that would allow the dimers to form with the histidine
instead of the arginine at the dimer interface?
In other words, can you make a mutant in RAF that will
now work with histidine in that position?
Yes, you can make an alanine. So if you put alanine in there,
it will still dimerize, but the histidine doesn't, and most
other mutations don't.
And so will that then restore the signaling by, say,
BRAF R to H?
Yes, I think it
will.
Okay.
I'm going to get you all that. Is it quick?
Mm-hmm.
Very quick. Stand closer.
Ed Clark. And I wonder if you've studied why the class III
hypoactive mutants have the higher affinity for the
membrane.
What was the beginning?
Stand closer. We can barely hear you.
Oh, boy.
The class III mutants-
Yes
... activate in a strange way or a different way, and it's based in
part on the affinity to the membrane, which is higher than that of the other
mutants. So have you studied that at all yet?
So we're starting to do that now, and in fact, the class
III mutants,
what we're seeing in our
test tube, which I didn't show you, is that they have an increased
also ability to activate CRAF.
And
so we think that they are really going through
CRAF, and
what Mark Thierman has shown is that they are no longer in an
auto-inhibited state.
Okay, we got to move on. So thank you, Debbie.
The last speaker is Ray Palay from NYU, and he's our Rising Star
awardee, and he's going to tell us about LCN2, right?
No, I mean LIF.
LIF. The other one.
Your other project.
Yeah.
I said to myself, "Say it right," and I did it wrong.
No worries. I just want to thank the organizers for allowing me to present my work
today related to ALKB1 mutant lung cancer.
So I have no disclosures.
So just briefly introduce ALKB1. So ALKB1, which is also known
as SDK11, is commonly mutated in lung
adenocarcinoma. You can kind of see the range of mutations that are occurring.
So ALKB1 occurs in about 20% of lung adenocarcinoma cases,
comparable to another mutation we study called TP1.
But unlike KRAS or EGFR, there are no targeted therapies against ALKB1
mutations. But what's clinically important about ALKB1 mutations
is that they tend to respond poorly to immune checkpoint blockade, such
as anti-PD-1 or anti-PD-L1 therapy.
And so the thought is that these tumor mutations somehow subvert immune
responses through unclear mechanisms, which I'm trying to illuminate
to some extent today, with the overall purpose to really enhance anti-tumor
responses in this genetic subtype of lung cancer.
And so a lot of the work that I do builds upon the prior work, looking at
ALKB1 by the Rubin Shah lab and Monty Winslow's lab, where they've
established that this ALKB1/SIK/RTCC2 axis is the key driver
of tumorigenesis. So they showed that loss of ALKB1 or SIK leads to
upregulation of a transcriptional program that drives
tumorigenesis. And this also relates to a lot of the immune evasion phenotypes that
I'm going to describe today.
So to model ALKB1 mutant tumors, we use this genetically engineered lung
cancer mouse model, this KP model, which probably many are familiar with.
And so we induce these tumors with a lentivirus expressing Cre, which
initiates autophinus tumors that express KRAS G12D and
loss of P53.
These models also express conditional Cas9, so we can induce gene editing,
such as losses of ALKB1.
And so this model recapitulates a lot of key features we see in probably human
tumors, such as these ALKB1 mutant tumors are quite more aggressive than
their ALKB1 wild type
tumors of these SG neo or non-targeting group.
But importantly, really getting to the immune evasion phenotype, the T cells
are poorly functional in these ALKB1 mutant tumors, and one of the common
readouts we use is looking at IFN-gamma and TNF-alpha production
within both of these CD4 and CD8 subsets.
And so as we were working on this project, prior to this, some of our
collaborators, including the Kwok Wong group, had established that these ALKB1
mutant tumors are also infiltrated with neutrophils.
And so for us to comprehensively essentially model or study the
immune landscape of these tumors, we performed single-cell RNA-seq, sorting
CD45 populations from this tumor model, and really understand what's really
happening with all the immune populations here.
And so this is our single-cell data from
immune cells isolated from this tumor model.
And there are two key striking components I want to focus on.
And so in the ALKB1 tumor context,
consistent with the Kwok Wong lab group, we see that there's increase in neutrophil
populations, but there are also kind of dramatic changes in the
macrophages. And these changes in both neutrophils and macrophages, I'm going to go
through one by one.
When we looked at the neutrophils, we were able to identify eight different
subsets, seen here. But the one I want to really focus on are
these populations that are highlighted here, which is these cyclic up-high
neutrophils, which are here in pink.And so these neutrophils
were first identified by the Ptech group
not too long ago, and they're essentially immunosuppressive, long-lived, and
tumor-promoting neutrophil subsets.
But we're really the first ones to identify that they're quite enriched in this ALK
immune tumor context, and this is specific to this mutation
as when we study other tumors, such as K1 immune tumors, we don't see this
elevation either.
Looking at the macrophage populations, we're also able to identify a range of
macrophage populations. But in the ALK immune tumor context, the ones to really
focus on are, we see this enrichment of these interstitial macrophages seen
here. And these are monocyte-derived or bone marrow-derived
macrophage populations that essentially infiltrate the lungs of these tumors.
And these macrophages also have two markers of immunosuppressive features,
one being highlighted here, which is these SBP1 macrophages, which are
seen in multiple solid tumor types and are associated with immune evasion.
And then when we look at other features, one key feature I'm going to be mentioning
throughout the talk is this ARG1 expression.
So ARG1 is arginase 1, which breaks down extracellular arginine.
It also impairs T cell function. And so this ARG1 is really
restricted to these interstitial macrophage compartment seen here.
And so this is from the total lung, and we're currently working with this company
called Stellar Omics, who does this 3D spatial transcriptomics.
And so we're trying to understand a little bit more about how these macrophage
populations are in relation to the tumors.
And so this is some preliminary data showing tumors at different time points.
These are the early and late time points, but focusing on the late time point, we
can see the tumors of these densities seen here, but we can actually see that
there's enrichment of these ARG1 macrophages actually throughout the lung and
really creating this immunosuppressive niche.
But so we're going to further analyze this to really understand how these
macrophages relate to tumor populations along with Stellar Omics.
But the data I've shown so far established that these ALK immune tumors are
infiltrated with these two main myeloid subsets,
these ARG1 interstitial macrophages, and these have high neutrophil
populations that are generally immunosuppressive.
And so for the next step, we want to identify what is driving this altered
myeloid infiltration. And we presume that there's some kind of secreted factor
that drives this repolarization and recruitment process.
And to analyze this or determine this, we essentially took sorted tumors from our
mouse model and performed RNA-seq.
And so shown on the left is the heat map showing the results of this, where these
are not the top genes, but these are selectively genes that we thought were
relevant to the myeloid populations.
So we see upregulation of CCL2, which can recruit monocyte-derived macrophage
populations, and then also CXCL1, 5 and 7, which can recruit
neutrophils, for example.
But we identified that the master regulator or a key
component of this is a cytokine called leukemia inhibitory factor called LIF,
which is transcription upregulated, but also even at the protein level,
when we look at BAL from these mice is upregulated.
And once again, this is not seen in other aggressive tumors such as K1 immune
tumors as well.
And so shown on the right is also TCGA data showing that this is
also upregulated in the setting of ALK immune lung adenocarcinoma.
So, so far what's known about LIF is that it signals through this
receptor called a LIF receptor and then binds to GP130, and then
one of the most common signaling mediators is through STAT3.
So in our tumor model, we see that these ALK tumors are enriched in LIF.
So we asked then whether there's active
LIF signaling, measured by phospho-STAT3 levels.
And so when we looked at this in two different contexts, the top being our mouse
lung cancer GEM, and then the bottom showing using human tumor samples, human
tumor cores that are lung adenocarcinomas.
In both contexts, when we stain for phospho-STAT3, we see elevation of
intratumoral phospho-STAT3,
which is demonstrated here and here as well.
So we see this elevated phospho-STAT3 suggestive of active LIF signaling.
So this led us to hypothesize that these tumors not only secrete
LIF, but then they also engage in autocrine LIF signaling, and that could be
driving the tumorigenesis and immune phenotype that we observed.
So to mechanistically dissect this, we used our lung cancer GEM model
and then generated ALK immune tumors with either deletion of
LIF or LIF receptor. And that way we can dissect whether
tumor-derived LIF or autocrine LIF signaling has an effect on these
phenotypes.
And so when we analyze these tumors at endpoint, which is roughly about 11 to 12
weeks after tumor initiation, we see that deletion of LIF actually
dramatically reduces tumor burden at this time point, showing that the
tumor-derived LIF is driving tumor growth.
But also when we delete LIF receptor, we see that this essentially phenocopies a
lot of the features of LIF deletion as well.
And so this shows that this autocrine LIF signaling is active and also a driver of
tumor genesis.
We also perform a single-cell RNA-seq from this model, sorting the
CD45 populations to then figure out what this autocrine LIF
signaling is doing to these myeloid populations and then T cells.
So in this analysis, we sorted CD45 populations, as I mentioned,
but we also included tumor cells to identify what
LIF signaling is doing within the tumors as well.
But first, we're going to look at the neutrophil populations shown here.
Now, when we look at the neutrophils, once again, in this ALK immune tumor
condition seen right here, we see an abundance of neutrophils, and especially this
immunosuppressive sigle ッ ク high neutrophil population right here.
But when we delete LIF or LIF receptor, essentially disrupting LIF signaling in the
tumors, we get a reduction of most of these neutrophil populations, including this
immunosuppressive subtype of neutrophils.
And when we look at macrophages, we see a similar reversal
when we look at the macrophage subsets which are identified here, but for
simplicity, we'll just look at ARG1 expression, and circled here are the
interstitial macrophages here. We see high expression in the ALK immune
tumor context, but in the tumors that have LIF or LIF receptor deletion, we
actually get a downregulation or minimal expression of
ARG1.So essentially, we see reversal of two
immunosuppressive myeloid populations when we disrupted or
essentially genetically deleted LIF signaling.
Now circling back to the T cells, those are key drivers of anti-tumor immune
responses. When we look at their cytokine production from the
CD4 and CD8 subsets, we see that in the tumors that have deletion of LIF
receptor, we have increased expression of these cytokines showing that or
suggesting that these T cells are more functional.
But to really show that these T cells are actually engaging in restricting tumor
growth, we performed also a T cell depletion experiment starting quite
early at week three, depleting both CD4 and CD8 T cells.
And so in the context of ALK bone immune tumors which are immunosuppressive and
T cell suppressive especially, when we deplete T cells, we don't see any change in
tumor growth after this eight-week treatment or a depletion.
But in the context of ALK bone immune tumors that have deletion of LIF receptor,
these T cells are active and actually restricting or curtailing the growth of these
tumors. And so when we deplete these T cells, we see acceleration of their growth.
And so all of this shows that this autocrine LIF signaling seems to drive this
immunosuppressive myeloid infiltration and then T cell suppression.
But for the next part, I'm going to go into what is this autocrine LIF signaling
doing to these tumors here. And to do that, we're going to analyze these
tumor cell subsets seen here that we included for a single-cell analysis.
So when we look at ALK bone immune tumors, we're able to identify eight different
tumor clusters or cell states. But the clusters I want you
to focus on are these clusters five and eight seen here.
These clusters have unique features that are high expression of, say, this
EMT signature, then loss of NKX2.1 expression, suggesting that
they're dedifferentiated populations.
And then clusters five distinguishes itself from clusters eight by this high
expression of PROM1 or CD133, and also this expression
of this transcription factor, SOX17.
And so we end up labeling these in consistent with some other papers, including
from the Myelomas group and Tamura Lab seen here.
But the general idea is that these ALK immune tumors have these well-differentiated
AT2 populations, but they also develop these more dedifferentiated populations,
which are clusters five and eight here.
The importance of these clusters are that we think that the inflammatory
genes that are involved in the myeloid recruitment and polarizations is
coming from these two clusters based on these signatures seen here.
And how these clusters get changed with LIF signaling.
So essentially, when we delete LIF or LIF receptor, these populations
get significantly depleted, showing that these clusters, five and eight,
these inflammatory and dedifferentiated population essentially depend on LIF
for their maintenance. And this is more easily seen on this stack chart
seen here.
And then circling back to SOX17, we believe that SOX17 is an
intermediate in this entire process.
So recall that SOX17 is highly expressed in this cluster five.
And so when we delete SOX17, we also get a reduction in tumor burden, and then
also a reduction in some of these inflammatory mediators we think are driving the
myeloid
polarization and recruitment, such as IL6, CSF3, and
CCL2. So we think that this ALKB1 actually regulates LIF
expression, and then turn in this autocrine signaling loop express,
controls this whole dedifferentiation process, and this is SOX17 serves
as an intermediate to that process and that inflammation that occurs.
And then the final part I want to talk about is whether we can target LIF signaling
in a therapeutic manner.
And so currently, AstraZeneca has an antibody that's in clinical trials that's
being tested in non-small cell lung cancer.
And so we used an antibody that's adapted from that inner ALK1
tumor model, which has high expression of LIF.
We initiated our tumors, and then eight weeks after tumor
initiation, these tumors are already developing that dedifferentiation phenotype
and are infiltrated with these immunosuppressive myeloid populations.
We gave an anti-LIF antibody for three weeks and then measured the same outcomes
like tumor burden and immune infiltration.
We see that with the anti-LIF antibody, we get a reduction or
decrease in tumor burden at this endpoint, but we're also able to deplete those
immunosuppressive populations, the cyclic of high neutrophils and Arg1
interstitial macrophages.
Now, we also did single-cell analysis in that same experiment with the anti-LIF
antibody. And when we look at the ALK1 tumors seen here, we're able to
identify similar populations, including these SOX17 EMT-like
populations. These are circled here, and they lack NKX2.1,
have high expression of SOX17, and they also express markers of stemness, such
as KIT seen here. But this LIF antibody seems to be able to deplete these
populations. And so once again, they either depend on them for their maintenance
and they either die off or they actually become more of these well-differentiated
states seen here.
And so to summarize, these ALK bone immune tumors are quite distinct from
ALK bone wild-type tumors, which have minimal immunosuppressive myeloid
infiltration and to some extent, active T cell surveillance.
These ALK bone immune tumors, they have transcriptional reprogramming,
including autocrine LIF signaling, and this drives the tumor
plasticity and dedifferentiation process, as well as the inflammatory
program that reprograms or polarizes these myeloid populations that
subsequently lead to immune suppression and then dampened anti-tumor immunity.
But we can use an anti-LIF antibody to block this process and then also block
all these downstream processes to restore the anti-tumor immunity process.
And so this work, if you want to read more about it, it's also currently available
online as of today.
And then with that, I just want to acknowledge everyone who's worked on this.
My mentors are Thalease and Sergei, and then Allie was my co-first author on this
manuscript, and then Yuan also helped with all our computational
analysis, and then all our collaborators, especially Shohei, who helped with our
antibody development as well. Thank you.
Other questions?
Okay, go ahead.
I seem to remember that there was a story from Tony Hunter a few years ago
on RAS regulation of LIF.
Mm-hmm.
And I'm wondering, so does RAS activation
make the LIF gene permissive for being turned on
following LKB1 deletion? So if you inhibit MAPK signaling, for
example, does that have any effect on LIF expression?
Yeah, it might. There's two contexts.
When we look at TCGA data sets, we see that KRAS LKB1
co-mutants have higher LIF expression than single mutants.
So there might be something to that.
And then we've also tried in LKB1 cell lines using, say, a RAS inhibitor,
and that also seems to decrease LIF expression to some extent.
It's still high, but it does decrease it.
So there may be some like kind of co-signaling between those pathways, too.
Okay. Lovely. Thanks.
Yeah. So, I mean, that was in pancreas cancer, right?
Yeah.
Sorry, what was that? That was pancreas-
That was in pancreas cancer.
Yeah, it was.
And it's KP. So that's actually a good segue to my question, which I guess
if there are no other questions, we'll sign off.
So,
Thomas Tenelle has shown that you get these
dedifferentiated states during the normal development of KP tumors, too.
Mm-hmm.
You would argue that that is or is not LIF dependent?
Yeah. So, at least in our context, we don't see any LIF at all at the protein
level. Maybe there is a small amount that contributes to that.
We've done genetic-
So do you think something else is doing that, and is that also an inflammatory
process?
Yeah, there could be a lot of redundancies, like even in that IL-6 family of
cytokines, like oncostatin or something, they might be able to do something
similar. We try to delete LIF in KP tumors, even though they have
minimal to no expression, and we don't see any difference on tumor burden, but we
didn't really look at that whole plasticity and dedifferentiation of these tumors
at all, so.
Ah, we have one more question. So we're still at time.
Yeah. It's interesting. Thank you.
I might have missed it, but I'll try to understand how a loss of
LKB1 could regulate your LIF expression.
Did you look at the mechanism of that?
Yeah, we looked at it, and it's actually kind of similar to what Reuben Shaw has
shown, with the LKB1 loss leads to inactive SIC, and then that
leads to CRTC2 and CREB activation of-
Okay
... a series of genes, including IL-6, LIF, all these cytokines, too.
So we did that. I didn't show the data here, but in vitro, we've shown that it's a
similar phenomenon. We delete CRTC2, we don't get actually that LIF expression
upregulation.
And is it AMPK dependent?
We haven't looked at that, so I can't say for sure, but it might well be.
Okay. Thank you.
Okay. Well, if there's no other questions,
we'll bring the session to a close.
And if anybody has any other questions, they can come up here.
We have a couple more minutes
for the session.